[Music]
yes in fact there's theory
he's happy with that there's also a lot of
practice because a lot of people
reproach us quite often in
academic circles for thinking
brilliantly and not too often
free and therefore in fact the way
today in confidence is organized
it is really to deliver in this
context sopra steria takes care with
freedom on the platform part but
that's not really what I wanted
you to  talking in fact what I was
talking about is ultimately not you are
all start-ups and you take
the industrial fabric as it is but
start-up and how we do it and
finally how the industrialist we
are  software as we work with
you 1 we need you that in the
end we are a bit of a nag and us
so the intelligence of brio is with
you we know a little about the customers
we have at some point built
solutions that  are based on an
assembly of your  products in all the
examples that you have seen I think
we can sell it to
people who are
of the same level who will understand the
same things but as soon as we want to
go up the ladder it is  much more
complicated than interest in
village huts so manufacturers like
us need us to make twenty-two groups of us,
but you may
need us a little too to build scalable
solutions
that we know how to sell then  I
'm not talking about promising there because the
years
[Music]
so here's the first point it's
building together a
dove solution and in our offers to us and
which in fart allow after or debris
second point in fact
there's a very big was going  write about the
pitfalls to avoid when you see a
good 45,000 people box with a start-
up basically if we don't do it for the q
because we put processes back on
stuff like that there are legal actions
and baths you breathe it
f  aut ask permission for all that
so all of them work with startups
it consists on our side in fact of
understanding that it does not exist it will not be
interesting it is because they are
agile and they can quickly
make  things so advice
number 2 is in fact c and d and not
controlled otherwise well pass we will redo
I think we will fold am so it
is still absolutely important for
us and then I will tell you what we
do is  exactly but still
important for us to keep this
agility and in fact bring it
access to the market we all win in
fact on the one hand we are able to
build solutions that we would
never have done on our own and  on your side,
you start to integrate them into
in schemes
there is something important in peace
you know what are the systems that are actually
put in place in sopra stars
there are three in general it's in  1 3
the first of them is in
fact a corpor  ate painting good it's
jean bernage you need
juice money
so a corporate painting is not a
vain capital killer we have no
vocation to make money with that
it can't be we are not  not
investing to win by incorporating
adventure it means that we have an
industrial project on which we need
at some point to integrate things
that we do not know how to do
and therefore at that time  we invest
at a level that never gives us
control
but that allows us to say well
it's towards the municipality you would like to
go because that's where bat where
we have an industrial model
and therefore we have a  a number
of examples in this
and in particular I started with when we
invest through funds for
example font brienne 3 on
cybersecurity in fact in the end we
have a good experience of sailor moon we
still need a lot of
things  innovative in it and therefore in fact
the Brienne fund invested in  s
start-ups in the field
we integrate them so that a first
first approach in fact
disintegrated them through through
the corporate it happens to us on
rare occasions but we have in fact done it
to intervene in  equity, that is to say in
fact to put money directly
somewhere and no later than this
week
we will sign a whole I can talk about it
because I said that I was going to talk
in a Franco-  American on
the somewhat intelligent chain blog in
which we fart we will even be just
putting convertible bonds
why because in the field of the
supply chain which was an
important thing for us because we are
in industrial circles so  no we
think that in logistics circles
and smart contrasts are an
important element
we also do the same on other boxes
especially at bank level b
in fact what the message that has behind
in fact is if it  there is actually no
subject  s industrial
if there is no industrial vision
if we do not leave complete latitude
in fact to the start-up to evolve at
that time it does not succeed in
the results of the races in fact it is
just for  tell you it's very
simple I gave you three figures
that Jean-Bernard actually gave
last year they have
about 4000 start ups they saw
about 300 and we finished at the end
concluding with 28
why not because it was
bad and others it's quite simply
that we didn't know how to do industrial man
what we wanted to do so thank you
very much for what you are doing
we need to
try you  need us and then
congratulations to all
[Applause]
[Music]